Hey, Wisecrack.
Jared here.
Okay, we’re about to do something a little
risky, a little crazy, and maybe even a little
sacrilegious: We’re criticizing Pixar.
Because even though it’s brought us the
tear-jerking joys of Inside Out, Wall-E, and
the Toy Story saga, its genius is not entirely
above some sloppy storytelling.
Turns out no studio can resist the allure
of a cash-grabby sequel, and that’s kind
of what 2016’s Finding Dory felt like to
us.
It just didn’t seem as emotionally resonant
as Pixar’s best work, and -- being the obsessive
nerds that we are, here at Wisecrack -- we
had to ask ourselves, “why?”
It’s worth mentioning here that, according to the Guardian, FINDING DORY underwent massive rewrites.
Were those rewrites to blame for our dissatisfaction
with the movie?
Is FINDING DORY a lesser film than FINDING
NEMO?
Is this simply a case of sequel-itis?
Are we just over fish stories?
Well, let’s filet this thing and find out.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition of Finding
Dory: What Went Wrong?
And, as always, spoilers ahead.
But, before we dive in, thanks to the team
at LastPass who helped make this video possible.
Like everyone you’re probably tempted to
use the same few passwords over and over again.
I mean, seriously, coming up with hard to
crack passwords and remembering where you’ve
used them is a just a pain.
Using the same passwords again and again,
is a pretty bad idea.
Sites like Tumblr, LinkedIn, even Domino's
have been hacked before.
And, with a constant flow of new data breaches
– it's nearly impossible to keep track of
which hacked site could be jeopardizing your
online security.
That’s where LastPass comes in.
It’s an online password manager that can
help you protect yourself and preserve your sanity.
Not only does LastPass help you create secure
passwords, but it also manages them for you.
No more hassles, no more remembering which
password is for which site, no more forgetting
where you wrote them down, no more getting
locked out of your accounts!
You can safely and easily surf the net and
avoid having to enter the first concert you
ever went to or your grandmother’s cousin’s
maiden name.
The free version is great, and if you want
the premium features like family sharing and
priority support, it’s just a couple bucks
a month.
Thanks to LastPass for sponsoring this video
and check them out at the link in the description
to get started!
And now, on with the show!
Finding Dory comes up short in at least four
key areas where FINDING NEMO excels.
For the sake of clarity, let’s categorize
these problems as: 1) Clouded emotional investment,
2) shaky narrative structure, 3) passive heroism,
4) purposeless entourage.
To be fair, these issues are almost impossible
to separate from one another, so there will
inevitably be some overlap.
But here we go, anyway...
First: the question of emotional investment.
A key objective of any screenplay is to get
the audience to care deeply about the protagonist
a goal that’s often achieved by first getting
us to care about whatever our protagonist
most values and/or needs.
Maybe the protagonist is focused on scoring
an internship...or going the distance in
the boxing ring...or on breaking free of a
suffocating life.
Whatever the case, in most strong screenplays,
that desire is established early.
It’s singular.
It’s powerful.
And it generates our empathy.
In FINDING NEMO and FINDING DORY, the protagonists’
goals are blatantly similar.
In the first film, Marlin searches for his
kidnapped son; in the second, Dory searches
for the parents she hazily remembers.
Although there’s nothing wrong with leaning
on the trope of the missing family member--
I mean, it works for Liam Neeson.
Finding Nemo and Finding Dory unfortunately
have different attitudes towards the magnitude
of loss.
That’s because only one of these films--
offers us a baseline before it rips a loved one away.
And it’s that baseline that creates emotional
connection between us, the protagonist, and
the protagonist’s need.
In other words, even though the bulk of Finding
Nemo keeps Marlin and Nemo apart, it first
offers a sense of what these family members
mean to one another.
As early as the first minute of Finding Nemo,
we’re told what Marlin values more than
anything else in the world: "These are our
kids we're talking about!
They deserve the best!"
And Marlin proves that value system through
his actions: In the film’s baseline moments,
we see Marlin pledge to protect his son, then tease his
son, then prepare his son for school, then bring
his son to school, and then lecture his son.
"You're about to swim into open water!"
"No!"
We have a sense of history.
So when Nemo gets kidnapped 15 minutes into
the film, we, like Marlin, have loved, and
we have lost.
We are invested.
Finding Dory offers no such baseline, so it
never offers the gut punch delivered by its predecessor.
In fact, Dory loses her parents within the
five minutes of Finding Dory.
In the opening scene of the film, Dory, even
to her own parents,
is positioned as something of a liability. A cute little goof.
"Okay sweetheart, what about the rhyme we learned?
We see the undertow and we say..."
"Let's go."
"No, no."
Shortly thereafter, like bubbles in a bathtub,
her parents vanish.
How much can we really be expected to pour
our emotions into losing characters we never knew?
"Well where are your parents?"
"Ummm... I can't remember."
If Finding Dory can’t get much mileage out
of the parent-child bond that energized Finding
Nemo, then what is the central relationship
here?
Where do we invest our empathy?
You might guess that we feed into the bond between
Marlin and Dory.
After all, they did spend a whole movie together.
They’re probably totally buds now, right?
"You know what you can do, Dory?
You can go wait over there.
Go wait over there and forget! It's what you do best."
Not really.
Seems the arc of personal growth that Marlin
and Dory experienced in Finding Nemo has reverted
here, with Dory now being viewed as a nuisance
by pretty much everyone.
Sadly, it isn’t until Dory is separated
from the relationships she formed in the first
film that we’re introduced to what is supposed
to be her source of support in this movie:
the, uh, bond-- between Dory and Hank, a curmudgeonly
octopus who wants only to exploit Dory for
the transport tag attached to her fin.
"No, no, no. If I just take your tag, I can take your place on the transport truck."
And, yeah, I mean that’s pretty much it.
That’s the nature of their friendship.
Heartwarming, right?
The emotionally deficient relationship between
Hank and Dory is almost entirely transactional
and deceitful, which doubles down on the film’s
empathy gap.
But later, FINDING DORY hastily tries to switch
gears, and that brings us to our second point...
2) Shaky Narrative Structure.
Take a look at most memorable films, and you’ll
find the protagonist making a key decision
right at the center of the story.
It’s a moment that reframes the protagonist’s
objectives and tests his or her resolve.
Some refer to this as the film’s “midpoint shift.
It’s no coincidence that the halfway mark
is often a major moment of self-reflection
for the protagonist; a turning point in his
or her journey...
"I'm with you now."
So what happens halfway through FINDING DORY?
Well, Hank reveals he's got a soft spot for
that loopy blue fish
"You'll forget me in a heartbeat, kid. Three heartbeats. I'll have a hard time forgettin' you though."
...but where did this sentiment come from?
It’s surely not earned by any particular
actions or moments in the film, itself, because
Hank and Dory are never really a team --and,
unlike Dory and Marlin, they’re never really shown
enjoying their adventure.
And, hey, come to think of it, Hank isn’t
even the protagonist here!
In any case, since Dory and Hank have almost
no moments of genuine connection within the
first half of Finding Dory, Hank’s change
of heart towards Dory, midway through the
film, can’t help but feel unearned.
"I don't care."
Contrast this with the realization Marlin
experiences in the middle of Finding Nemo.
"And maybe he wouldn't have done it if I hadn't been so tough on him."
Here, Marlin begins to recognize the error
of his overprotective parenting style.
And this realization is a direct result of
his control-freak behavior nearly getting
Dory killed.
Throughout Finding Nemo, this midpoint shift
and other character-revealing moments are
directly motivated by cause and effect.
Nemo is motivated to put his life in jeopardy
because he learns his dad is heroic.
"Your dad's been fighting the entire ocean looking for you!"
"My father?"
Marlin is motivated to team with Dory because
he realizes Dory can read.
"Wait a minute. You can read?"
"I can read? That's right! I can read!"
Later, Marlin is motivated to separate himself
from Dory because he thinks his son is dead.
In Finding Dory, however, key moments in the
story, like Hank’s change of heart towards
Dory, are largely motivated by convenience
and necessity.
They are simply what need to happen to move
characters from point A to point B. Later,
Dory refers to Hank as:
Even though evidence of any such sweetness
is scarce at best.
But, hey, in this movie, being an ass is pretty
easily forgiven, as long as you pay lip service
to some sort of growth.
Deep into Finding Dory, Marlin tells Dory.
"Ever since I met you, you've shown
me how to do stuff I've never dreamed of doing.
Crazy things."
But even this sentiment, too, seems unearned,
because it leverages moments from the first
film -- in which Dory and Marlin adventured
and grew closer together, rather than from
this sequel, in which they are either separated
from each other or annoyed.
Nevertheless, this moment is meant to play
as a moment of self-awareness and maturity
from Marlin.
Which raises the question: what is Dory’s
key moment of self-awareness in Finding Dory?
"You remembered in your own amazing Dory way."
Wow. You’ve got to wait until the movie is nearly
over to find out!
And this illustrates Finding Dory’s third
setback.
Passive Heroism.
For much of the film’s running time Dory
operates as a passive protagonist.
one who responds to events rather than create
opportunities.
Some of this tendency is due to her all-too-convenient
memory flashes-- which handily take the story
wherever the screenwriters need it to go.
These flashes, and even the occasional undertow,
are driven more by chance and proximity than
as a result of personal effort or growth.
Although, sometimes it's almost as if the film is suggesting Dory's disability can be willed away.
"I remembered something!"
This perspective seems, um, fishy at best.
And it doesn’t leave Dory with many opportunities
to demonstrate her ingenuity and development.
Events often happen to Dory, rather than because
of her, and that’s never a recipe for great storytelling.
Of course, another cause of Dory’s passivity
is the nature of the film’s actual environment.
After the film's first twenty minutes, Dory
quite literally becomes a fish out of water,
a status which restricts her movements to
the whims of other characters.
How much can we expect our protagonist to
be the master of her own fate when she’s
being carried around in coffee pots, baby
buggies, or a bucket that’s labeled “Destiny”?
By trading the thrilling blue ocean of the
first film to the claustrophobic, human-centric
clinical spaces of Finding Dory, Pixar ultimately
hamstrings the scope of the story it’s able
to tell, and the degree to which its protagonist
can help tell it.
Dory, then, isn’t a driver of her own story,
she’s a passenger -a passive responder to
triggered memories, an odd partnership, and,
very often, blind luck.
But at least her personal motivation remains
relatively clear.
"Do you know anyone who lost a kid a long time ago that would be me?"
She wants to find her parents.
And so, if we’re willing to buy into the
premise of the film, we must simply want to
find them, too.
Even though Dory’s desire to see her family
is very conveniently triggered by the school
of fish saying the word "undertow" it’s true that Dory’s
ultimate objective is never in doubt.
But the same can’t always be said for Marlin
in this film.
And it’s even less clear for Nemo, who, at this point, seems in desperate need of Child Protective Services.
And this leads us to... The Purposeless Entourage
I’ll pause here, to ask a simple but important
question: why does Finding Dory involve all
three of these fish?
And does Nemo’s involvement actually negatively
impact our feelings about Dory and Marlin?
That’s right - Marlin, having just a year
earlier crossed the perilous ocean to save
his only surviving child, now agrees to drag
that same child with him to guide Dory all
the way across the ocean again simply because:
"How can you be talking about the view when
I remember my family?"
Um, okay.
But this springs from the studio’s need
for a sequel, not from clear character behavior.
Ultimately, Finding Dory commits the sin of
asking Marlin and Nemo to undermine so much
of what made Finding Nemo powerful.
After all of the emotional investment we as
an audience made in Nemo’s recovery in Finding
Nemo, Finding Dory asks us to believe that
Marlin, responsible father extraordinaire,
is willing to risk his own son’s life on
the basis of Dory’s hunch about her parents
she hasn’t seen in years.
And no, I’m not being hyperbolic: Nemo really,
seriously almost dies-- I mean, couldn’t
Marlin find a babysitter?
Why is Nemo part of this new adventure?
Why does Dory, who presumably cares about
Nemo’s safety, agree to pull him along on
a dangerous mission to serve her own personal
agenda?
The film mostly bypasses these questions,
and -- if we are to enjoy it -- so must we.
But we should all take a moment to at least
recognize the weirdness of ending a fish movie
with a car chase on the freeway.
And, hey, look at that!
Dory’s a passenger again.
In her own movie.
Thanks for watching guys. Peace!